all right in this video we're going to
be multiplying monomials together let me
give you an example of a monomial 4x
squared that's a monomial
now why well mono means one which refers
to the number of terms so this 4x
squared this is all one term so what so
we're going to be working with things
like that what won't we be working with
well what about 4x squared plus 5x how
many terms are there for X Squared's the
first term 5x is the second term so this
is not a monomial this is actually
called a binomial because by means to
like your bicycles got two wheels for
example so not yet go on to the future
videos if you're ready for binomials but
we're just going to be working with
multiplying monomials together so can we
grab an example to look at by the end of
this video it should be very easy for
you to multiply this monomial 5x squared
by this monomial and I'm actually going
to just give you the answer right here
and then I'm going to slowly walk you
through some other questions that will
lead us to why but the answer to this is
20 X to the 8th 20 X to the 8th take a
look at that see if you can notice a
pattern what do we do with the 5 and the
4 to get the 20 what did we do with the
2 and the 6 to get the 8 that's getting
a little ahead of ourselves though
before we can dive in there let's
remember some of the exponent properties
a very specific exponent property that
you should have seen before so we look
at 5 squared times 5 to the fourth power
what's that going to equal well if you
remember your exponent property and
we'll do a quick reminder here I always
add my exponent so 5 squared times 5 to
the fourth power is equal to 5 to the
sixth power what about 3 to the fourth
power times 3 to the fifth power
well again I always add my exponents 4
plus 5 is 3 to the 9th power and my base
of 3 stays the same great so if you
remember that now we're now we're ready
to really start multiplying monomials
that are new to you and the new thing
here is that we are going to have
variables involved so let's start by
let's take a look at two monomials here
the first monomial is 4x and the second
one is just X and the 4 I don't have
another number to multiply by it just
got the 4 and can I simplify x times X
well that's equal to x squared remember
if I just have a variable and there's no
exponent there it's equivalent to having
a 1 so X to the first power times X to
the first power
I add my exponents like we just talked
about and 1 plus 1 is equal to 2 great
so let's move on to another one here 540
times 3t well 4 times 3 is going to be
equal to 12 so I've combined my
coefficients and then T times T again
think of a 1 being there is going to be
T squared so the answer here is 12 T
squared so let's keep going and once you
get into the rhythm of these they become
pretty alright so what if I had 4p to
the fifth power time just say 5p to the
third power what would that equal we're
going to notice a pattern here that
we've been picking up on which is that
I'm always going to multiply my
coefficients so 4 times 5 is going to
equal 20 and I'm always going to add my
exponents so P to the 5th + P to the 3rd
is P to the 8th power so I multiply 4 +
5 to be good 20 I'm add 5 + 3 to get 8
and if you really want to see why that
is let's really
dive in here and let's break down this
first term let's break down for P v I
can write that out as four times P times
P times P times P times P that's five of
them it's four and five PS and then that
second term I can write as times five
times P times P times P what I'm going
to do is I'm going to group my numbers
because I can work with numbers together
so let's put four times five at the very
front and that just becomes a matter of
how many peas do I have we'll put all of
those together as well so I had five
peas so there's the first five and then
I had three more and we can simplify
this crazy-looking expression by just
multiplying by four by five to be my 20
and then writing this with an exponent
that's the beauty of exponents that why
that's what we have them is we can write
a crazy expression like that as P to the
a then you'll notice that this is of
course what we got the first time so
great about five y to the sixth times
negative three y to the eighth eighth
power again multiply the coefficients
add the exponents and I've got a
simplified expression let's get really
crazy here let's have a little fun
so we've noticed the pattern let's have
a little fun you're saying I can do any
more negative 9 X to the fifth power
times negative three
use parentheses there you always when
you have a negative in front you will
use parentheses it's 2x to the 107 power
if I would have showed you this before
this video you de said oh my goodness I
I there's nothing I can do on box
there's there's no way out but now you
know that it's as simple as follow the
rules we're going to multiply the
coefficients negative 9 times negative 3
is 27
two negatives is a positive in 9 times 3
is 27 I'm going to add my powers 5 plus
107 is a hundred and who not to that was
almost two that was a mistake I made
there let's get rid of that give me a
second chance here it's all about second
chances 5 plus 107 is 112 and so this
crazy expression which is two monomials
here's the first here's the second when
we multiply and simplify we get another
monomi which is 27 X to the one iron
Club I'm going to leave you on a
cliffhanger here which I'm going to show
you a problem
well variables should we use you notice
I've been trying to vary the variables
up to show you that it just doesn't
matter that's ugly Phi let's get rid of
that you make it give me a second chance
of that one too so let's let's look at
5x to the third power times 4x to the
sixth power and I'm going to show you a
wrong answer I had a student that I
asked to do this and here's the wrong
answer that they gave me they told me 9x
to the 18th power that's terribly wrong
what did they do wrong what did they do
wrong I want to think to yourself what
have we been talking about what did they
do with the 5 and the 4 to get the 9
what should they have done what did they
do with the 3 and the 6 to get the 18
and what should they have done that's
multiplying monomials by monomial